donating toys to the shae tree which is
an organization that
helps battered kids and battered women
and we are so grateful to contribute to
them and for every toy that
the people bring in uh top's actually
gonna match it one for one so we're
gonna double these toys and we're gonna
make a bunch of kids happy and chop is
the owner of the tobin auto group so
doing so much for the community as
always so what kind of toys are you guys
looking for what can we bring i have
barbie here and i got bay blades and we
got mr potato have any unopened toys
rocky anything that you guys can
contribute uh would help greatly okay
okay and we can do this until december
15th at each of your locations here in
the valley auto mall tell them which
locations so
any location in the tobin auto group we
have tobin kia
tobin alfa romeo and fia and then we are
in the od store tobin dodge
store
you guys have been in town here since
1998
yep 1998. bringing joy to the community
adults alike as well as the kids because
you guys have been giving us amazing
cars for so long yeah of course of
course and we we're happy to to provide
such a great experience for the
customers the kids come in they have fun
the dogs come in they have fun so that's
what it's all about we're just gonna
have a bunch of fun this holiday season
well speaking of fun you know after you
come in and you buy a car or you donate
your gift
you gotta hit the gong okay so make sure
you come down to the valley auto mall
between now and december 15th donate
your toys talk to hiram find him
and get all the information you need
i'll send it back to you
our great toy drive continues with the
help of tobin auto group and telus
international you can drop off a new
unwrapped toy or even a gift card at any
of the dealerships on your screen the
donations will benefit the shade tree
organization